-This week has revealed a lot
about the Trump White House,
from peddling conspiracy
theories to attacking immigrants
to defending an aide
accused of domestic violence.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Donald Trump so badly
wants to be a dictator,
but no one seems
to take him seriously.
Maybe it's his name.
"Donald Trump"
just isn't a good dictator name.
It sounds like the name
of the chubby I.T. nerd
who doesn't get the girl
in a college comedy.
"You'll never guess
who asked me out.
Donald Trump."
[ Laughter ]
Still, this week has brought us
one unnerving spectacle
of authoritarianism
after another,
from the President
calling Democrats treasonous
for not applauding him
to ordering the Pentagon
to plan a military parade.
In fact, Trump's request
for a military parade
is so crazy that even
state TV outlet Fox News
seems a little
uncomfortable with it.
-Jennifer, what has been
the reaction at the Pentagon
to the President's request?
-Well, I would describe it,
Dana, as a collective eye roll
from military leaders
who I've spoken to.
Most thought
it was a joke, at first.
Many fear that the U.S.
will look like the dictators
they scoff at around the world.
-There are a lot of people
at the Pentagon
who would love to show off all
the equipment and personnel.
-I don't know.
It seems like a waste of money.
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
When you've lost Brian Kilmeade,
you know you've gone off
the deep end.
That's like
Thelma telling Louise
she's just gonna catch an Uber.
[ Laughter ]
But while they may be skeptical
of Trump's plan
for a military parade,
Fox News and the rest
of Trump's allies in the GOP
have been helping him concoct
a series of fake scandals
to undermine
the Russia investigation,
like, for example,
the famous Nunes memo,
alleging wrongdoing by the FBI.
The memo turned out
to be a dud,
but that didn't stop Trump
from pretending
they'd uncovered
a massive scandal
during a speech in Ohio
on Monday.
-Oh, but did we catch them
in the act or what?
You know what I'm talk--
Oh, did we catch them
in the act!
They are very embarrassed.
They never thought
they would get caught.
We caught them.
Hey, we caught them.
Oh, it's so much fun.
We're like the great sleuth.
-I'm sorry. You are...
[ Laughter ]
You are not a great sleuth.
You might think
you're Dick Tracy,
but you're only half right.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
So, Trump's allies in Congress
and the right-wing media
have going all out
to discredit the Russia probe,
and yesterday,
they latched on to yet another
wild conspiracy theory
when a text message
from September 2016 emerged
between former FBI officials
who were having an affair,
in which one wrote to another...
Now, Fox News tried
to claim the text
was a reference
to President Obama
meddling in the Hillary Clinton
e-mail investigation,
but if you look at the timeline,
that doesn't make sense.
In fact, it turns out
the text was actually about
Russian interference
in the election,
a topic any competent President
would obviously
want to be briefed on.
Of course,
if that text were sent now,
under Trump, it would read...
[ Laughter ]
But as usual, the fact
that this fake scandal
was yet another dud
did not deter Trump,
who took to Twitter
to scream in all caps...
This keeps happening.
Every time the right
claims to have discovered
some major bombshell
casting doubt
on the Russia investigation,
we get a little more context,
and it turns out to be B.S.
In fact,
the same guy who brought us
this fake text scandal,
GOP Senator Ron Johnson,
also brought us a fake
text scandal a few weeks ago
when he claimed
to have found a reference
to a so-called secret society
in a text message sent
by those same two FBI officials.
-What this is all about
is further evidence
of corruption --
more than bias but corruption --
at the highest levels
of the FBI.
And that secret society,
we have an informant
that's talking about a group
that were holding
secret meetings off-site.
There is so much smoke here,
there is so much suspicion.
-Let's stop there.
A secret society,
secret meetings off-site
of the Justice Department?
-Correct.
-And you have
an informant saying that?
-Yes.
-Man, look at Bret Baier's
face right now.
That's the face you make
when someone comes up to you
on the subway
and tells you pizza rat
was a government
mind-control project.
"He didn't want the pizza, man!
They just made him think
he wanted the pizza!"
[ Laughter ]
Now, when the full context
of the message came out,
it turned out
it was just a joke,
which anyone with any
common sense could've told you.
And Johnson was eventually
forced to admit
that the whole thing
was probably a joke
when he was tracked down
by reporters in the Capitol.
-Senator,
this text message seems to be --
the comment about
a secret society was in jest.
Do you agree that it appears
to be it was in jest?
-Oh, is it?
[ Laughter ]
Is it a real possibility,
Detective Johnson?
I'm sorry to say this,
but you're not exactly a...
-Great sleuth.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Now, while all of this
is happening,
Special Counsel
Robert Mueller's investigation
seems to be moving very quickly,
and his team has made clear
that they would like
to interview Trump soon,
but this week,
Trump's lawyers have been
telling him not to comply.
-Lawyers for President Trump
say he should not agree
to sit down with
Special Counsel Robert Mueller.
That is according
to "The New York Times," saying,
"Lawyers are concerned
that the President,
who has a history
of making false statements
and contradicting himself,
could be charged
with lying to investigators.
-Of course, they are.
Trump lies like a rug,
and like his rug,
he's not very good at it.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
♪ The best thing
that ever happened ♪
-No lawyer
who has ever met Donald Trump
would let him sit down
for an interview under oath
with Robert Mueller.
In fact, I'm pretty sure
one of the first questions
on the bar exam is, "Would you
let Trump talk under oath?"
and the only two choices are,
"No" and "Hell no."
So you've got the President
ordering military parades,
calling his political
opponents treasonous
for not applauding him,
and spreading
conspiracy theories
to undermine
a federal investigation.
And then there's the fact that
Trump has been openly lying
about immigration policy,
and just two days ago,
called for a shutdown
of his own government
if Democrats refused
to bend to his will.
He was so adamant about it,
he kept repeating the word
"shutdown" over and over.
-If we don't change it,
let's have a shutdown.
We'll do a shutdown, and it's
worth it for our country.
I'd love to see a shutdown
if we don't get this stuff
taken care of.
If we have to shut it down
because the Democrats
don't want safety and,
unrelated but still related,
they don't want
to take care of our military,
then shut it down.
We'll go with another shutdown.
[ Laughter ]
-Why does
he keep saying "shutdown"?
Is that his safe word
for when he's confused
and bored in a meeting?
"Well,
this is all very interesting,
but I was thinking
we need a shutdown!"
[ Laughter ]
"Let's have a shutdown!"
"Time for a shutdown!"
Also, can we...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can we go back
to this part real quick?
The Democrats
don't want safety and,
unrelated but still related,
they don't want
to take care of our military,
-"Unrelated but still related."
[ Laughter ]
That sounds like
how Trump would describe Eric.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
"This is, uh...
This is my son."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"This is my son Eric --
unrelated but...
sadly, related."
[ Laughter ]
Now, leaders in
the Senate yesterday
reached a deal
to keep the government open,
but that agreement did not
include a fix for Dreamers,
the young
undocumented immigrants
who were brought here
as children
and whose lives
were cruelly thrown into limbo
when Trump ended the program,
and to protest the fact
that the deal doesn't include
a solution for dreamers,
Democratic leader Nancy Pelosi
took to the House
floor yesterday
and gave an unprecedented
eight-hour floor speech.
Now, Pelosi has become something
of a target for Trump lately,
who's been bragging he wants
to make her
his de facto opponent
during the 2018 midterms.
Trump even went out of his way
to criticize Pelosi
during his speech
about the GOP tax cuts in Ohio.
-Nancy Pelosi, what
she's doing to this country.
And she's gone so far left.
I think this is not
a good day for Nancy Pelosi.
She's our secret weapon.
Your paychecks are going way up.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Your taxes are going way down.
So Nancy Pelosi, again,
said that's crumbs.
Well, she's a rich woman who
lives in a big, beautiful house.
-So Trump seems to have trained
his sights on Nancy Pelosi.
I wonder what it is
about Nancy Pelosi
that seems
to attract Trump's ire.
I mean,
Trump attacks a lot of people,
but there's something
in particular
that really seems to anger him.
I can't put my finger on it.
It's really a mystery.
Well, I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
I guess we'll never know.
We'll just never know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But there's something.
In fact, the Trump White House's
misogyny and hostility
towards women were once again
on display this week
when administration officials
initially defended
the White House staff secretary
Rob Porter
after he was accused by two
ex-wives of domestic abuse.
It was reported that
senior White House officials
were aware for months
of the allegations.
No action was taken
to remove him from the staff,
and after the allegations
surfaced Tuesday,
the White House
strongly defended him.
Now, the allegations
against Porter were reported
by two different publications
and corroborated by photos
and contemporary sources,
but still, the Trump White House
initially defend him.
In fact, this is a White House
that has repeatedly chosen
the denials of men over the many
corroborated stories of women,
whether it's in the case
of Roy Moore,
Corey Lewandowski,
or Trump himself.
-Yeah, we've been clear
on that from the beginning,
and the President's
spoken on it.
-I can only say
Corey's a fine person.
I told him, I said you should
never settle this case.
You should go all the way.
I think they've really hurt
a very good person.
Roy Moore denies it.
That's all I can say.
He denies it.
And by the way,
he totally denies it!
-Trump sided with those guys
even though
they look so guilty.
Roy Moore is what
Howdy Doody would look like
if he checked in
to a rehab clinic,
and Corey Lewandowski looks
like he should be
slowly rising out of a basket
while music plays.
[ Laughter ]
Porter resigned yesterday
despite Kelly
and other White House officials
defending him.
And in the wake
of Porter's resignation,
this photo of a group
of key Trump aides
from a July 2017 event
has resurfaced.
Look at that photo.
Everyone in that photo has
either resigned or been fired --
Lewandowski, Omarosa,
Anthony Scaramucci,
Sebastian Gorka, and Porter.
Even the car in the back
has been fired.
[ Laughter ]
Melania kept trying to escape
in it, so it had to go.
So if you're in the photo,
it means eventually,
you'll be fired.
And I know it's cheating,
and I don't know --
maybe this will work?
There we go.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]